à madiana plage sévit un empoisonneur un
esprit suffisamment déranger pour
déposer jour après jour du poison à la
portée des animaux domestiques aux
sauvages comme des enfants sans
surveillance
l'individu a fait au moins huit victimes
cette semaine le chien d'un riverain et
sept chats certains venaient tout juste
d'être stérilisés par une association
ces chats étaient présents pour la
plupart en grande partie donc depuis
plusieurs années on les suivait on les a
fait stériliser souvent avec nos propres
notre propre argent
c'est un investissement personnel énorme
et tout ça bien sûr c'est parti on va
dire en fumée en même pas une semaine en
quelques jours ça a été fulgurant lundi
matin tout le monde était là nourrissage
mardi matin il n'en manquait déjà 4 et
après ça s'est succédé chaque jour on a
trouvé des corps sans vie de nos chats
auquel nous tenions énormément à
quelques pas de la plage les animaux du
voisinage sont directement menacés et au
bord de l'eau ce matin
ces baigneurs ne comprennent pas c'est
pas cool et c'est ses succès dans jouer
de faire ça moi même ont fait justement
qui aiment toucher à tout ce qui traîne
interne
il peut jouer avec après je t'aimais
quand même avant la substance sous ses
mains se frotter les yeux se met dans ma
bouche et puis et je ne sais pas qu'est
ce qui s'est passé que nos enfants
ensuite il est malade
mécha sur la plage ça vous a déjà
dérangée poser des problèmes non pas du
tout j'en ai déjà vu des chaussures là
sinon jamais dérangé 1 comme il y en a 3
2 chez moi aussi là où j'habite où la
montée et s'est sûrement il me dérange
pas du tout il voit pas pourquoi on
dévoilé des tués quoi on doit les
empoisonner je comprends pas
particulièrement cruelle et sournois
l'empoisonnement vise surtout les petits
félins d'indiana ans les bénévoles
devrait précisément à la lutte contre
leur prolifération
c'est la volonté du législateur qui
protège aujourd'hui les chats libres
l'article l211 27 du code rural et
l'arrêté ministériel du 3 avril 2014
confie la gestion des chats sont
familles aux associations en coopération
avec les mairies la loi préconise la
capture des félins en vue de leur
stérilisation puis leur retour sur le
site
ainsi nul n'est plus en droit de les
piéger en vue
or élimination ni publique ni privée dès
lors qu'il existe des associations
locales
la réglementation est largement bafouée
mais pourtant très rationnel si les
associations se retire du site
on va se retrouver avec une
surpopulation féline assez rapidement
c'est à dire en l'espace de 2-3 mois
avec une centaine de chats qui vont
réapparaître les gens qui se plaignent
soi-disant divers achats ce n'était pas
le cas puisque ces animaux et et
vermifugé donc il n'était pas porteur de
problèmes de ce type là donc là ils vont
se retrouver véritablement avec tous les
problèmes dus à une surpopulation féline
dues aux abandons dans toute l'île le
nombre d'empoisonnement interpelle dans
le code pénal tout acte de cruauté
envers un animal domestique ou
apprivoisé peut exposer son auteur à
deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30 mille
euros d'amande